Maze’s End is a card that sat in the back of my
trade binder, as well as in the back of my mind,
for ten years. Simply get ten gates, and then
you win the game—it was always an intriguing
card in the way most alternate wincons are, but I
could never find a good reason to build a Maze’s
End deck. Every so often I’d come back to it, most
notably to ponder a Child of Alara commander deck
early last year, but it wasn’t until September
that I finally found a good vehicle for it. See,
the issue with Maze’s End is that it’s both
visible and slow—opponents can track the
progress of the deck to its wincon with pinpoint
accuracy, and the timeframe to arrive at that
wincon leaves a long period where opponents
can apply pressure. In addition, the 10 gate
requirement means that deckbuilders are encouraged
to play a sequence of pretty mediocre taplands,
or else need to activate Maze’s End a large number
of times. However, there is a way to get around
all these problems—what if I simply played all the
gates at once? Cards like Scapeshift and Reshape
the Earth allow deckbuilders to do just this,
getting all the necessary gates for Maze’s End
out all at once. This can leave a full turn cycle
before victory due to the lands entering tapped,
unless a player has an Amulet of Vigor in
play, or rather, an untapped turtle friend.
Causing all other permanents to enter either
tapped or untapped depending on his own status,
Archelos is a fantastic vehicle for this sort
of deck because not only is he a combo enabler,
he can also help out with ramping faster as well
as slowing down opponents. In addition to running
12 gates, the deck ended up running several bounce
lands to give a mana boost with the commander,
some basics to be grabbed with land-grabbing
spells, and a handful of other utility lands,
for a grand total of 43, not including Maze’s
End. Of the two cards that allow the deck to win,
one costs nine mana and the other requires ten
lands, so naturally ramp ends up being a very
big part of this deck. There are 20 dedicated
ramp spells as well as an additional four
ramp spells that serve double-duty by also
offering a way to tap down the commander,
and being able to force everyone’s stuff to
enter tapped until my next turn is a pretty
sweet side benefit. From there, the deck mostly
consists of draw, tutors, and interaction.
The most potent of the deck’s tutors is
Emergent Ultimatum, a card that basically
serves as an additional combo piece, since any
combination of Reshape the Earth, Scapeshift,
and Boundless Realms will result in getting
enough lands to win. As far as interaction goes,
I always like to have a lot of counterspells
in my blue combo decks, so this deck runs
eleven of those and six other cards intended to
control the state of the game in some capacity.
The deck took a lot of tweaking to get to the
point where it functioned appropriately—how
much ramp? How much draw? What sort of lands? How
should the deck go about surviving and preventing
opponents from winning? How important is the
commander, and how much should I be leveraging
him for non-combo purposes? I spent several
weeks and dozens of hours tweaking and tuning
and pruning and answering tough questions until
I’d achieved the seemingly impossible—a deck that
could pull off a Maze’s End win consistently by
turn 7 or 8 with plenty of interaction held up,
all for a bit of over a hundred bucks. It was
an accomplishment, a realization of my past
ambitions, an optimized utilization of a silly
alternate wincon card I’d been thinking about
for ten whole years. And, if the story ended
here, it would be an unambiguously happy one,
an uncomplicated tale of self-actualization
and cardboard triumph. However, it was in
fact somewhat complicated by a simple
fact—Magic the Gathering is a card game,
and decks are meant to be played in games
against people. In my first few games with the
deck I was kind of surprised with the way people
responded to me pulling off my massive land
swing—I’d get excited and start grabbing gates,
and other people would basically just go “oh you
got the combo? Okay cool, another game?” I had
constructed a grand narrative for this deck,
because it was genuinely challenging to build,
but in an actual game of commander this plays
just like any other 1 card + commander
combo deck. Satisfy conditions, get pieces,
stop opponents from winning long enough to put
things together, protect combo, and do the combo.
It’s not necessarily that the deck was
entirely uninteresting or entirely devoid
of fun gameplay—it’s an acceptable combo deck. The
real surprise was the expectation vs the reality
of the situation—I had constructed narratives
of grandeur as I was reaching out, striving for
a powerful Maze’s End deck, but once it was
in my hand it was clearly something far more
mundane than I had expected. And, on some level
it’s a little strange that this happened to me,
because I had watched my friend Hans have a very
similar experience a few months prior building a
Yidris deck. This was a deck that used Yidris’
unique combat damage ability to cascade into
an “each opponent discards their hand, you draw 28
cards” combo off of two cantrips. It was otherwise
built in a midrange shell, containing ramp,
removal, value engines, and some very specific
protection spells that were chosen in order to
still get value when they were cascaded into. So,
what was the problem there? Well once
again, despite having a creative execution,
this deck’s combo was still a combo, and
opponents treated it as such. In fact,
this deck was even more problematic than the
Archelos deck due to the fact that all of its
shenanigans could be stopped by simply killing
or fully blocking the Yidris, and since not doing
that meant possibly ceding a massive value swing
to the Yidris player, players would religiously
hate out Yidris. On paper, everything lined up
for the deck, but real life is not made of paper.
MTG AS A TWO-PHASE GAME
A question I’ve asked myself is, what are these
decks saying exactly? They say something about
combos, and about humans, and about how
we build decks, but that’s not the most
interesting thing they say. The most interesting
thing these goofy combo decks tell me is that deck
building creativity is not rewarded in and of
itself in games of commander. This might sound
like the whining of some hipster, but I’m not
intending that statement as any sort of value
judgment about the state of the game—rather,
it provides an interesting jumping off point
for thinking more critically about the game and
how it’s experienced by the people who play it.
An inherent weirdness of a collectible card game
like Magic: the Gathering is that deckbuilding
and playing are two separate phases of the game.
You’re not playing Dominion or some other card
game where deckbuilding and playing happen in
tandem; no, these things are clearly demarcated.
Limited formats provide the most conventionally
game-like structure for these phases, in the sense
that a four or five hour limited event literally
contains separate timed phases for assembling
decks and playing the game. A Magic: the Gathering
draft, where players pick cards from packs in a
circle and build decks with their resulting card
pool before entering a series of timed rounds,
actually resembles a lot of board and card
games in structure. As a simple example,
For Sale is a game that contains one phase where
players bid against each other on property cards,
and then a second phase where players use their
lineup of properties to secure point cards. Like
a Magic: the Gathering draft, the first phase
involves a mixture of strategy and luck to
determine how good a player’s group of cards
is, and then the second phase uses the quality
of that group as well as some further strategy
and luck to determine the ultimate outcome of
the game. This is a clear enough line to draw
with limited Magic: the Gathering events, but
the relationship between these different phases
gets progressively more convoluted from here.
Let’s think about a low-level Standard event.
In the deckbuilding phase, players on their own
time and in their own spaces complete the task
of assembling the best standard deck they can,
and the best sideboard to face off against
the decks they expect to face. Then,
the playing phase sees the players, now
congregating in a game store at a specific time,
play a sequence of games to determine a winner.
This is very different from most games in that
different phases occur in different settings on
different timelines, but the structure is still
roughly the same. The first phase sees players
complete one goal, which then contributes to the
outcome of a second goal. However, taking things
a step further into the realm of commander,
things get even murkier, because you lose
a lot of the element of competitiveness.
The first phase does still involve building a
deck, and the second phase does still involve
playing that deck, but the goals are much
less clear. Unlike a standard tournament,
there usually isn’t a prize for winning
an EDH game aside from bragging rights,
and even in store-run casual commander events
the subject of prize support is one with no
shortage of disagreement and controversy. Put
simply, winning isn’t codified as a goal in the
same way as it is in 60 card constructed events.
This difference in how winning is perceived then
trickles back down to the deckbuilding phase. If
everybody was sincerely trying their best to make
the most powerful deck in that deckbuilding phase,
commander games would be full of netdecked cEDH
lists, but most players choose to show up to EDH
games with decks that look quite different than
that. Winning will be a contributing factor to the
sorts of decks that EDH players will build, but it
will be accompanied by a melange of other factors
rendered subtle in competitive 1v1 formats—wanting
to do a certain cool play, wanting
to have a deck feel a certain way,
wanting a deck to look a certain way, wanting a
deck to produce the funniest moments, and so on.
A lot of these goals will mesh well with the
task of having fun in that second phase—obviously
players playing decks that feel expressive or
cool to them in some way will usually lead to
them having more fun, and the goal of winning will
likewise produce a lot of fun moments for people.
However, there are also other goals that don’t
mesh as well with having a fun game of commander,
and the best example of these is decks that try to
win in some especially creative or expressive way.
As it turns out, winning the game is generally
a pretty brief process. A long period of back
and forth can be fun, but when a game reaches a
point where one person is all but guaranteed to
win it’s generally for the best that things stop
there. This is also why nondeterministic combo or
lockout decks are often unpopular—they stretch
out the length of a win, requiring opponents to
make an unfortunate choice: either concede to
save time, or waste an extra 10 minutes on the
5% chance that the comboing player fizzles. But
okay, I’m getting off topic. The platonic ideal
of an EDH win is brief—there is no ceremony where
the winning player gets to revel in their glory
and be celebrated for their deckbuilding or
gameplay accomplishments, the game just ends
and people move on to either another game or
any of the other things that might occupy their
life. Winning in that creative way might be cool
for that first time or two, but maybe not even
that—the really memorable games are usually the
ones where something unexpected happens, not the
ones where a player trots out their creatively
devised wincon they spent hours creating.
THE FIEND HUNTING PHASE
But, spending hours to creatively devise and
perfect a wincon still has an allure to it,
doesn’t it? Despite understanding all of what I
just said, I have a pattern of continually coming
back to build new creative combo decks—it’s
an itch that I can’t seem to stop scratching.
Another one I built in paper a few months back was
one I like to call Tribal Fiend Hunter. The basic
idea behind it was this—you know Fiend Hunters,
those creatures that exile something else until
they leave play? Well, what if you built a deck
with the goal of getting three of them and then
having them exile each other repeatedly in an
indefinitely long loop? Just a few fellas having
a really phenomenal day of fiend hunting. This
is a somewhat unique spin on a combo deck—instead
of finding a handful of different pieces in
separate categories, you just need to find
three of the eight Fiend Hunters that exist within
the green white color identity. The deck then wins
through some means or other—a couple of the Fiend
Hunters also create tokens or counters, and three
of them exile multiple cards, which allows for
infinite ETB triggers. Speaking of ETB triggers,
I went with the commander choice of Torsten,
Founder of Benalia. Torsten has a lot of benefits,
with the biggest ones being that he draws a bunch
of cards on ETB, a fact which can be paired with
cards that flicker in order to draw the number of
cards that the deck needs to draw in order to find
three Fiend Hunters—37 on average. So, the deck
began with a mixture of Fiend Hunters and sources
of blink. From there, most of the deck ended up
occupied by lands and ramp creatures—42 and 29,
respectively. This might seem like a lot,
because it is—I have a 7 mana commander to cast,
and since he’s the only source of draw in
a deck that wants to draw a ton of cards,
the deck doesn’t really do anything before he gets
cast. The mana dorks of the deck are carefully
selected to offer the most utility during the
Fiend Hunting combo step—there are 6 different
ones that can give infinite mana, infinite
+1/+1 counters, or some other resource that
can hopefully lead to winning, and the deck’s
removal likewise fits into this mold. Overall,
the goal here was to have a combo deck that
is as fluid and flexible as possible, using
the power of Fiend Hunters to creatively piece
together wins in a variety of different ways.
Initially I considered including some pricier
cards in the deck like Preston the Vanisher,
or even switching the commander to Atraxa
for a four-color version, but eventually
I came to the conclusion that I did not want to
spend more than $50 on this deck. The logic was
this—I knew that I found the Fiend Hunter combo
funny, but I had been down the funny combo road
before and the resulting deck didn’t end up fully
feeling worth the money I spent on it. With that
in mind I figured there would be two reasonably
likely possibilities—either this deck ended
up being a hilarious blast to play and I’d keep
finding reasons to pull it out, a situation worth
well more than $50 to me, or it’d end up being a
novelty that I’d get a handful of funny games out
of before more or less being shelved, a situation
worth around $50. Sure enough, the reality of the
situation was far closer to the latter. The deck
functioned pretty amusingly once it was up and
going, and it would typically combo off around
turn 7 which isn’t half bad for a $50 deck,
but this came with a catch. The 7 mana
commander and the fact that all of the
ramp was creature-based meant that the deck
was extremely disruptible—killing a couple
mana dorks in the first few turns of the game
would immediately set the deck back several
turns. This deck was carefully crafted with just
barely enough of any given resource to function,
and this ended up being its biggest weakness—the
deck just has too many possible ways to kneecap
it to keep up in most high power casual
games. The deck wasn’t a total failure—it
was a success of budget deckbuilding, and a
success of my own ability to show restraint
and know when I shouldn’t spend too much on a
deck. However, it was still yet another goofy
combo deck that didn’t really succeed at
being a deck I’d want to play long term.
The Archelos deck and the Fiend Hunter deck are
the only two I’ve built in paper, but there are
several other goofy combo decks I’ve workshopped
and considered online decklists for over the past
several months. There was that polymorph deck
whose only three creatures were Trench Gorger,
Balustrade Spy, and Timestream Navigator, with
the goal being to mill my entire library before
taking infinite turns. There was that Brinelin
Dargo deck that had the goal of casting Dargo
a large number of times before doing—something, I
honestly don’t remember what at this point. There
was also that time a patron’s deck sent me down
a rabbit hole of trying to build Rograkh Storm,
a deck with the goal of casting Rograkh an
arbitrarily large number of times before Jeska-ing
my opponents for some absurd amount. I’ve had
enough sense to not build any of these three,
but still—why do I keep finding myself in
this place again and again? Fundamentally,
I think it comes down to looking for a sense of
accomplishment. Let’s go back to the two phases
model of Magic: the Gathering gameplay. Unlike a
60 card constructed tournament where winning is
the #1 goal during the playing stage of things,
outside of cEDH there can be any number of goals
during this phase of a commander game, each
holding varying levels of priority. Winning
will be one for most players, but beyond that
players kind of need to pick out what they are
looking for from a game. Are they trying to have a
fun, social experience? Are they trying to impress
other players, to do a cool thing? Are they
trying to mimic a game of Uno? Are they trying to
assemble the largest collection of women looking
left in the Western Hemisphere? Ultimately,
players end up creating their own goals for the
playing phase of games, either consciously or
unconsciously, and these goals will then serve as
a guiding force during their deckbuilding phase.96
THE WONK FACTOR
An underrated factor that I’d guess affects almost
all players in this format is aimlessness—the
human brain goes a little wonky when it doesn’t
have enough structure to guide it through any
given task at hand, and for a lot of players the
amount of structure that the commander format
provides is an amount that puts them in that wonk
zone. It’s not hard to figure out why—the format
contains almost every card ever printed, and
doesn’t have set in stone parameters for what
decks should do or how powerful they should be.
For newer players in the format building with what
they have on hand, trying to build the strongest
deck possible will likely keep them occupied for
awhile, and this is indeed quite often to see with
players who have just discovered the format and
are looking to explore the limits of what they
can do with it. This is because player skill,
budgetary restrictions, and card pool
restrictions can serve as limitations,
things that a player will be optimizing against
whether they’re aware of it or not. Even after
players have gotten to the point where they
are capable of building more powerful decks
than they could previously, they will oftentimes
still seek out limitations in some form or other,
such as budget, aesthetic, mechanical,
or otherwise. These sorts of limitations
can be quite helpful for maintaining a focus
while deckbuilding—I frequently build with a
budget restriction of some sort, as this has
dual benefits of preventing me from spending
more than I want to as well as giving me
a parameter to optimize against. I have
an extra too many words to say about the subject
of constrained optimization as applied to Magic:
the Gathering that would derail this video with
a torrent of tangentially-related mathy bullshit,
so that stuff is going to be in an
extra posted over on my patreon.
Long story short, constraints can provide a
nice guiding hand in the deckbuilding process,
and they can present goals that allow players to
have more fun while building decks. However, they
will often be less felt within a game. Building
a Volo deck you might choose to have all your
creatures be different types, and that might pose
a fun challenge during the deckbuilding process,
but once you’re in an actual game, odds are
you’re just gonna be playing generic snowbally
midrange. Likewise, building decks with the goal
of accomplishing a cool or unique play pattern can
be a fun puzzle to solve during the deckbuilding
phase, but once you’re playing actual games,
that cool plan won’t necessarily translate into
an interesting game. So what does translate into
an interesting game? Well, when I look at all
of my decks, there are two decks that stand
out as being the most consistently fun ones—my
Radha deck, a greedy cascade battlecruiser deck,
and my Sharuum Slide deck, a cycling-based
toolbox control deck. These two decks share
three key attributes—consistency,
flexibility, and resiliency.
By consistency I simply mean that these decks
always do something—they don’t generally have
bad games and they are always doing something to
further their gameplan. By flexibility I mean that
what precisely these decks are doing can vary
a lot and can be shaped to the game they happen
to end up in. Though both decks lean toward late
game domination, they also both have ways to put
on some pressure if there’s another deck that
is at risk of getting too far ahead. Finally,
by resiliency I mean that these decks are
hard to fully shut down. My Radha deck is
iconically resilient due to its focus on basic
lands, a seldom-hated resource—nothing short of
reducing this deck’s life total to zero will
really shut it down. The Sharuum Slide deck
is somewhat more hateable, but it is still
fairly resilient due to how many different
ways it has of building resources—it has a
graveyard plan, it has an artifacts plan,
it has an Astral Slide ETB flicker plan,
it has a flying creature beatdown plan,
and it has a hand-sculpting control plan—there
are just so many different elements working in
tandem that if one or two get knocked out the
deck can simply pick a different direction to
build advantage in. You may find different
deck attributes to be enjoyable than I do,
but these are just the three that have
proved most consistently fun for me,
and they’re a good starting place if
you’re not yet sure what you find fun.
A final additional element that these decks
share is that their engines and interaction
suite are well-defined but their wincons are
less well-defined, because they’re both late
game decks—the Radha deck is looking to build
up an absurd land count and then win, and the
Sharuum Slide deck is a control deck that wants to
gain a degree of dominance over the state of the
game before it finishes off opponents. To me, this
goes back to the length of wincons—because these
decks have states they’re trying to achieve
rather than discrete plans to win the game,
winning games is more of an involved process
than it is in most of my other decks. Whereas
with a lot of decks the “win” is quite rapid once
the deck is in a good position, with a slower,
more controlling deck there will be more time to
simmer in the win. That’s certainly more enjoyable
for me while playing commander, and I think it’s
useful to identify that, but I hesitate to call
it an unambiguous good—is it good for the table
if I always pull out this sort of grindy endgame
deck? Is it good for me to always pick this sort
of fun-optimized play experience for myself?
At the end of the day, there is a valid place for
novelty decks out there. In spite of everything,
I’m ultimately glad I built both my Turtle Gates
deck and my Fiend Hunter deck—they were fun to
build, and it’s nice to have a bit of extra
variety around if I’m ever starting to bore
of my first or second string decks. It’s valid to
have different decks that serve different desires,
and not every deck needs to be some sort of
optimal construct of mathematically maximized
fun value. It’s even valid to build a deck
primarily for the enjoyment of building it,
and whether or not it ends up materializing in
paper can be a matter of personal preference.
What I would advocate for, however, is
mindfulness. When you’re building a deck,
it’s good to calibrate your expectations and
understand what that deck is going to mean for
you. Get to know yourself—what do you find fun?
What goals do you strive for in the gameplay
stage of things, and how can you contribute to
those goals in the deckbuilding stage? Is it
worthwhile to introduce constraints, and how will
those constraints affect the gameplay portion of
things as compared to the deckbuilding portion?
Because ultimately, a holistic understanding of
the game needs to include both of these things.
Deckbuilding is playing Magic on some level—it’s
just playing Magic in a different way than
the games themselves, and to different ends.
Thanks for watching! This was an expansion on a
Patron-only video I released seven months ago—I
finally felt like I had enough to say to turn
it into a full-length video. If you wanna see
me chew on ideas weeks or months before
they actually end up in a public video,
you can support me over on Patreon. My
lovely Patrons, some of whom are on screen
now, make it possible for me to take my time on
longer videos like this one, and without even
needing to include midroll ads. Beyond that, if
you’re feeling inspired to buy some funny combo
cards or some non-funny non-combo cards, I left a
TCGPlayer affiliate link down in the description.